today I want to give a big shout out to
member a believe nation Devon Trish so
if you don't know devon has been a loyal
member believe nation for a long time is
always commenting on the videos you see
him hash tagging up his BTW a number
hashtagging team motivation always such
as positive force for good on the
channel and then recently sent him one
of the belief t-shirts and he made an
awesome video on it that i wanted to
share with you guys well so this devon
trim team motivation TV and guess what
came in the mail today you got a package
for my good friend Anthony Mina
Carmichael and uh let's see what it is I
already know what it is what y'all don't
so let's open it up check it out see
what we got y'all hit up ok yep it's
official i've got my belief shirt Evan
Nina thank you again for the shirt I've
been I appreciate the believe message
you know watch your videos daily and
it's just a constant reminder that man
today it's time to get up and take
action if you want to make your dreams a
reality too so first you have to believe
also have faith I'll try this on and see
if it you know see if it fit all right
if it's pretty good thank you again
Sivan Churchill team motivation TV can't
stand steel cut the word among without
you so thank you Devon for the awesome
video thank you guys for watching make
sure to go check him out will link up
his channel on the video in the
description too much love guys continue
to believe and I'll see you soon